live going live in three two
paul the way you did it you sounded very
confident by the way yeah
did you hear that like it's
paul has what is known as the irrational
cause we're officially live i wish you
would have seen the way paul set us up
to go live
but we're officially live now on the
podcast this is episode number
42 or 41. is it 40.
number four jackie robinson we have adam
here with us we have a friend of ours
sonata ajem
right here a top luxury
realtor you've been doing real estate
for how long now the top the top uh
in all of boca she's number one and
maybe in all the world yes
no no no but here she's she's uh here's
all i can say to i went to um
i went to uh uh what is that waldorf
astoria yeah of course
i'm having lunch over there after we had
a visit together it was
yourself marcus me my wife and we looked
at the house in bel ray
where you know the one on the other side
i don't know which one if you know which
one i'm talking about
no we went to see a house in royal
palmyat and country club i think that
was the one
we did but we also looked at the one
with uh the rocky brook one yes
so i came back we're having a lunch at
this uh restaurant
the girl comes back i have the flyer
sitting right there she says
so you work with her i said i work with
who it's me
jen you know kids you work with her i
said i'm sorry i don't i'm confused
sonata i said uh no but we just met her
real nice you know we met her husband
she says well i hate to say this but i
have to say it anyways i said what is it
says she's a competitor of ours but
she's the best here if you work with
your very good hands
i'm just telling you everything
competitors are giving a shout out free
body solutions
sonata sonata sells 10 20 30 40 million
home so it's not you know it's a
different market you're in but it's good
to have you
on here with us for some that don't you
know we'll get into your story here in a
minute i think you used to be a top vp
with the trump organization years ago
you came out here you've done incredible
here yourself
in real estate and with the current
state of things i think it's probably a
good idea we talk a little bit of real
estate you educate us on that
and then and then since you're from
bosnia yeah
you also have some thoughts about what
zlatan said about lebron james i can't
wait to hear your commentary
but uh uh let's get into some of the
time before we get into it can we also
welcome a special guest back to the
podcast who's that kai
you baby it's good to be back you've
been in hawaii you've been driving
what's going on i watched what you guys
did what you did with
kai and tom it was fun watching you guys
you hosting sitting on this side it was
exciting to see that
i kept your chair warm but we're glad to
have you back but it's good to be back i
mean obviously hawaii was a
a great experience it's 12 hour flight
and when i lived in l.a was a five-hour
flight when you're living here
you got the flight the stops all that
stuff but we we were the biggest
event hawaii had an
elite incentive trip we had about 450
people there we had we were the biggest
events since covet
everywhere you went it was on the news
they were all talking about it they were
so excited to see tourism coming back
that's really good
they were so because that's how they
make their money and hawaii took a very
big kid during covet but it was a great
experience
you know good times i got some thoughts
i'll give at the end of the podcast we
ought if we had a phenomenal time in
hawaii
now that you're in florida floridians
don't go to hawaii for vacation they go
to the bahamas
they go to jamaica they go to uh saint
bart's even whatever we like to
challenge ourselves we go to
yeah we move here i'm going to florida
and i'm flying the exact opposite
direction that's
double dose but you had an awesome trip
we had a great time and the tan is on
point
yes we had a great time the kids swam
non-stop we ran into
uh armond from rafi's place you're
kidding me he came out you know you
didn't know everyone was gonna be there
i had no idea that's what
he messages me saying don't tell me what
you're gonna tell me i said i'm in my
mouth he says you gotta be
ten minutes away kids hung out with this
place we had a great account now we're
trying to get him to open up a raffia's
place in florida but we'll see if that's
gonna happen i think florida needs a
rafi's place oh yeah i agree with south
florida you can eat outdoors and
doors all year round baby exactly
exactly
let's get some real estate on that let's
let's make it out let me give the
stories on what we're going to cut let's
go then we're going to focus on sonata
and then we'll go into the story too i
think that's the formatting so
well here's the issues we got going on
today walmart is thinking about
coming out with the bank of walmart and
they just recruited top two top
goldman sachs folks away which they're
not just anybody we'll cover that here
in a minute
uh new york wall street journal did an
article saying the old new york
will not be coming back obviously a lot
of people are thinking the old new york
will be coming back they're saying it's
not going to happen
uh we'll see what's going to happen
there dow jones surges 600 points as
johnson johnson announces their new
coronavirus vaccine debut
texas top electric company files for
bankruptcy i think it's a 2.1 billion
dollar bankruptcy after what took place
and you would have never thought for
this to be taking place
everybody was surprised by it we may
cover that male fraud united airlines
paying 49 million dollars for scamming
the usps
for years this was happening now they
got to cut to check buffett
in his annual meeting that he had he
made a lot of different statements
number one he bet on america says always
bet on america
then he talked about fixed income invest
investors may face bleak futures bonds
we'll cover that
and uh some other announcements about
him buying back 25 billion dollars
repurchase
i mean when you're buying back shares
like that what are you saying about your
company confidence
i feel we're going places you buy 25
billion dollars back
that's respect for what data we'll cover
that chinese businessman charged with
stealing g
trade secrets the cpac speech i don't
know if you guys watch it or not i watch
the whole thing
you know it's it's he made a lot of
comments what may cover some of the
stuff that he said
hyde had some issues with that and then
we have let me see what else we got here
minimum wage iran nuclear deal syria
strike
biden administration urges
urge to penalize saudi crown prince over
the khashoggi killing
we may cover that and then twitter had
some stuff and obviously we cannot do
all of this without the zlatan
commentary of what he said with lebron
james which just so you know i'm a
die-hard zlatan fan
i am a die-hard slotten fan but this may
be a damn
yeah i'm a die-hard zlatan fan but we'll
go to that here in a minute so
real estate uh tell us a little bit
about your experience with real estate
how long you've been around and what's
going on today
for the buyer for the seller for the
investor what are your thoughts on real
estate market today
real estate is on fire um i have
never seen anything like this ever
before i mean
i've been doing it for 20 years now and
i've lived through the recession and
the irrational exuberance of 2005 and 6.
but what's happening now is so
extraordinary
in that the luxury sector
is facing such low supply
and such high demand that we're all in
awe
and just observing like what's going to
happen next so
i'm really fascinated by this huge
exodus from new york
i was just talking with adam earlier all
of the new yorkers we know are now
living in florida so it was all about
tax situations a lot of tax refugees
coming down tax refugees
yes wow and a lot of families who are
coming for lifestyle
and it's a whole different bowl game now
particularly you know when you're
talking about corporate relocations you
have
goldman sachs you have kkkr they're all
coming down here so
and and do you think this is going to
stop with new york or do you think this
is going to continue
i think this is going to continue not
just because of
tax benefits of of being here but also
because people
post covid or hopefully we're in the
post covered world
have realized that they want a little
more space
they want a little more air to breathe
and less density so i think it's going
to continue
like this it's interesting you say low
supply
high demand so you you put a house on a
market and we're not talking about 500
000 homes million two million dollar
homes
you put a house on a market 27 million
dollar house
boom like this gone two three offers
closed done 30 days 60 days
yeah and then you know tim you were good
friends with tim you know tim are our
shout out to tim elms who is a uh he's a
genius realtor he thinks like a tom
ellsworth
he's just his brain doesn't stop he's
just concerned one time when i looked at
a house it was the greatest experience
it was pure showman
we had such a great time so we go in
we're looking at this one house
and it's me and jennifer tim walks in
he looks at this realtor and says right
off the bat why the hell would they put
this right here
why would the builder put this right
this is 1980 stuff
and him and the realtor get into an
argument right in front of us i'm like
tim just it's okay buddy
and then he walks and says where's the
pantry how do you not put a pantry into
a four million dollar house you get
where's the pantry do you expect them to
put in the garage
so i'm like is there an issue going on
here with these two guys so then they go
outside he says
let me see the backyard there's a pool
and there's no fence there's a little
bit of a creek back there says nope you
got to put a fence here there's going to
be alligators there
he says sir i've been selling homes here
for 30 years there's not a single
alligator i
guarantee you alligators are going to be
found in your swimming pool
so at this point jennifer just steps
away and we're just sitting there
they're going for 15 minutes fighting
we're just cracking up
that's tim elms he represents you very
well or whatever
he's a good friend together he's a good
guy so
he said to me says patrick i just want
you to know
people who are moving here are
billionaires so if you're going to make
an offer
just know who you're going up against
there are people that have money that
don't care about 28 million 32 million
get what you want but don't over
negotiate right now because of what's
going on
obviously we've gone through a few
different homes and we've seen them go
like this just our own experience
absolutely so so how long do you think
it's going to stay buyer's market
because my concern is with rates right
we saw last week
the rates went up slightly and you saw
the market
you know respond to it what's going to
happen when powell or whoever is going
to be running the federal reserve
eventually raises the rates back to what
there used to be five
six percent what's going to happen there
do you think this number is still going
to be going up the market's still going
to be going up i think so i think the
strength of the luxury real estate
market is directly correlated with the
strength of the
stock market so it's it's psychology
right if you feel really good about your
portfolio and
you're like no i'm staying here i'm
gonna buy upgrade i'm gonna buy
something
bigger but the rates are impacting more
lower up to three million dollar segment
so
people who need to finance right and
however rates are going to impact the
stock market i think then it's going to
impact the
ultra luxury so so not the ultra so the
ultra luxury because it's a niche
they're not going to be affected by it
but other folks who are maybe in the 500
000 1 million 2 million they will be
affected by that absolutely
okay interesting because is that because
the ultra rich keep getting richer and
to them it's not a big deal to
you know move into place and you know
even overpay for property
pretty much i mean it's it's emotional
and it's a completely different ballgame
when you're dealing with
super rich versus when you're dealing
with people with families who
have to buy at a particular price they
have very strict budgets
so it's it's much more emotional driven
and what i've noticed
it's all about psychology right so when
when things are going
really well and particularly um during
the pandemic when people were scared
times of uncertainty bring out the best
in people or the worst in people so
fear fear is a very unique motivator
even with the super rich clients
so just this is a trick question for you
what is the cheapest home you ever sold
i don't know uh seven hundred thousand
seven hundred thousand
okay so seven hundred thousand all the
way up to
uh 25 27. okay so 700 000 to 25 27
what is the when you're dealing with
approach approach with a 700 000
client versus a 25 26 million dollar
client the reason why i asked that is
because you know i mean
i worked in finance last 20 years so i'm
dealing with a client that wants to put
a month into a term policy and they just
want to protect themselves for a hundred
thousand or a quarter million
that's all they can afford right i'm
just gonna put i'm gonna set aside a
hundred dollars on a mutual fund
versus you're dealing with a client
that's talking about you know
a hundred million dollars a bigger
number it's a completely different
approach with them
is it for you as well it is a different
approach but
it boils down to a common denominator
and that's the needs
right what do those people need if a
family
is really driven by um you know
relocation job is here so he
let's say a husband doesn't want to
commute to too far then we're just
really strictly focused
on on that with the ultra high net worth
clients
it's a completely different approach and
that their needs are
let's say you know where my kids are
going to go to school
am i going to have space for the staff
am i going to have the ability to work
from home
because most of these clients are big
ceos and
they want to have the ability to have
um huge offices at their home and the
pandemic by the way has had a huge
impact
on how people think and what these needs
are you know before was just
um i need a house
now it's more like i need a home because
i get to be stuck
in my home for so long so my perception
of the space
has you know transformed it's a that's a
good point because you're
you know many people are working from
home for the last 12 months
sonata how easy is it for you to sell
people from
all other states to move to florida if
you were if you were the governor of
florida
recruiting recovery okay governor
governor
okay is kind of like governor perry
would go to california and he would
recruit everybody and he would do all
these radio you
if you're a small business owner you're
going through high regulation and you
don't like the taxes why don't you come
down to texas you know
is that your rick perry that's kind of
what happened we met with rick perry and
he brought in nolan ryan don nelson he
says let me tell you about texas
and any incredible recruiting approach
that they had but if you were the
governor of florida how would you
recruit people to the state of florida
oh my god i almost want to tell him to
slow down
[Laughter]
governor desantis take it easy buddy no
it's almost like
is that what it is it's like a thousand
a day coming to florida so
we need to be able to keep up with the
infrastructure
and uh but it's so easy to recruit
because it's like
look at this lifestyle you know and and
also it was
the pandemic was horrific for so many
people and so many families
and they look at florida not just in
terms of lifestyle like we go out to
um restaurants and it's not as
strict as most other states so they look
at florida like
wow you guys are having fun like what's
going on it's so crazy you say that
you know you post instagram stories and
people will say well
lucky you you can go to a restaurant i'm
like lucky i mean
because i lived in texas right and even
in texas we'd go to restaurants and we'd
go
out yeah of course which i miss martin
you know our friend from
france so we go to toulouse and you're
sitting there you're having a good time
great everybody would send messages how
are you able to do that yeah why are you
able to do that understanding you come
to florida same exact thing here
but uh that's not normal for everybody
else that's normal i think this is such
a bubble it's almost la la land
in florida due to regulations
um during and post covid uh due to
the weather right due to low density
areas so
it's it's a whole different bowl game
what's going on here so easy time
recruiting people to florida
i don't need to recruit them how often
do you hear a luxury real estate agent
saying
relax we don't need you here right now
buddy i've sold enough stuff 20 million
homes let me take it easy well let me
ask you opposite question can you sell
people on staying in florida
staying in new york um new york
wow that's a million dollars
i think a lot of them are thinking of
coming down
relocating the companies families
everyone so um
i think the once once the weather gets
better in new york and once
post cover time has improved right i
think
um a lot of people will want to stay in
new york but new york there's something
so special and magical about new york
and it's so resilient i think it's going
to transform
but for now florida is the place to be
i'm not just
for business reasons and what you were
talking about taxes right
it's it's the place to be so what's
going on in new york right now like
obviously supply and demand you talked
about demand is ridiculously higher in
florida
supply is low flip it i mean we're
talking new york
new jersey connecticut just that whole
area
what's happening with the real estate
market there are prices down
20 percent like can you get a good deal
on it like if you believe
in new york and new jersey and you're
like look things are weird now but by
things are gonna be back to normal maybe
we're good what's happening in that
market from what you you've seen
from what we've seen in new york is
definitely down in terms of real estate
prices are down anywhere from
25 percent to some instances 35.
yeah so so if you bought a place for a
million bucks in new york which is this
is a shoe box in new york wow yeah
your condo whatever it is because i have
a buddy that just bought something like
right before the pandemic
his place is maybe worth 750 now that's
correct so real estate doesn't always go
up
like news flash well right i mean
correct okay and
and you are getting down you're dealing
with a black swan of course your course
is crushed
we're dealing with you know you got
really really crushed and ideally now
you want to sell in florida
at the high and buy in new york of
course so low
because the problem we're having in
florida a lot of people
with sexual inventory here is like you
tell them hey i can get you
insane number for your house and they're
like where do i go
i have no place to go if you sell what
do what am i going to do
do you ever recommend that somebody this
is i don't know if we want to open up
this can of worms on real estate but
sell your house okay get 10 million
bucks put in your pocket sick
go rent the place for a year or two do
you ever recommend that
i do i do like cash out and
cash out relax travel they don't like
the rentals
they just don't like if you're that
wealthy you're like no i need to buy a
place
no they don't most of my ultra-wealthy
clients like
if it's a few months here and there
they'll rent and if it's a beautiful
home of course they're fine with that
but in their mind like
they are not renting they're not renting
but new york to go back to your question
which is a really important
subject new york real estate
is down because it's a black swan event
and because people were afraid during
the pandemic to be in these
high rises and being around so many
people and and kobe restrictions were so
extreme rightfully so at that time
because new york was just a
unique place so i think it's going to
take a few years to recover
because it's affected
people on all different levels right and
it's affected
um how people think about new york real
estate but knowing
what new york is about which is it's
extreme diversity
and amazing you know people culture
everything yeah it's gonna come back and
now i have clients who will call me
and say hey do you have something in new
york that's a steal
so a lot of them are wanting steals in
new york as an investment because
they're counting
it's going to take two three years for
it today you can get these deals right
now are there steals yeah
so there aren't many steals in new york
right now okay that's good to know
so dharma so i just pulled up bank rate
and i looked up to see housing heat
index which state real estate markets
are doing the best and worst during
chronovirus they rank all top five
that's awesome top five number one you'd
never guess it utah
okay utah wow number one is utah believe
it or not what's up with that
it jumped up 10.7 percent in 12 months
then it's montana
maybe you ought to consider montana be a
good place for you then it's missouri
yeah then it's arizona then it's idaho
florida's not in the top five
it's maybe number six but it's not in
the top five it's what we're looking at
then if you put bottom five bottom five
check this out
51 hawaii okay
50 new york then it's louisiana illinois
nevada
even illinois got hit and but new york
50th
by the way hawaii homelessness was
berserk like
you couldn't even believe it well it's
like the most expensive place to live
it's not only the most expensive it's
not it relies on tourism exactly
so new york doesn't necessarily rely on
tourism new york is a you know business
capital of the world
but you got to keep the business there
right absolutely you know you got to
keep the business there
sonata you came your story is you came
from bosnia
why don't you share with us briefly your
story well
we actually have a lot of a lot in
common in that regard um i lived through
the war in bosnia in 1992 i was a
teenager i was 13 years of age
and so more atrocities and horrific
things than most people will will see in
their lifetime
and i worked for the united nations at
the time and and got a chance
once in a lifetime a chance to come to
the united states to study
and you know we were refugees during the
the war in bosnia
um we lost absolutely everything i also
lost my father
and it was you know a pretty big deal
for me to come to the united states
because it paved the way to
help all my family to come here were you
the first in your family to come to the
united states
wow yes i was the first one i came with
200 in my pocket
and a scholarship which was cool pretty
cool
and worked really hard ended up
getting my undergrad degree moved to new
york worked in
uh healthcare venture capital and then
got an opportunity to work for
donald trump so it was the most unusual
experience in that you know i'm an
immigrant i'm a woman right um
i used to be a refugee and coming to
work in the big city
um was pretty awesome that's why i have
such a soft spot for new york i love new
york so much
in in that place people welcome you with
your differences with what you have to
contribute right
and um after being there for about five
years
six years i decided um
they're meeting with trump organizations
yes yes so after being in new york with
the trump
organization with trump international in
particular i decided it was time for me
to um have a little bit of an easier
life
because working let's say 80 hours a
week
is good for a few years expectations
um and after you know doing that for
five years you come to a point you're
like okay i need
to relax a little so i moved with
blackstone when they bought the boca
resort i moved here to boca raton and i
love this little place
and i used to get teased a lot by my new
york friends like boca raton like
seriously it's such a what would they
tease you about it
it's a sleepy town it was known at the
time 13 years ago as the retirement
community and it's so not that
um so if you move to boca raton you're
going to have to deal with that as well
yeah i know i mean that's that's what
they told me when we were coming on it
but
honestly we came here the way the way
they described it was the best
say miami you got palm beach okay
you can even go jupiter if you want to
pace and speed of lifestyle
more south faster more up you know
slower
yeah i like a little bit of pace but not
too much
boca is a good place to be in the middle
exactly pacing so
so you're saying so you work with trump
obviously directly you guys work very
closely together was he a pretty intense
high standard guy
himself he was and was he like one of
those guys that's always on
where he'd come in to work he was also
working hard himself he wasn't just
expecting you to work hard was he also
always working hard himself he was
always working hard himself so
you know i we would start at like 7 30
or so and
i'd be there until 10 30 11 and um
we call him mr t so he would come in in
the morning to see who's there who's
who's the first one in the office where
what time would he get in the office
i don't know eight o'clock eight o'clock
step it up donald
trump i've already been in the office
for three hours buddy not you adam
not you step it up don't stop it not
sure adam's a 9 30 guy
after you do your yoga that's with my
yoga yeah you relax
well what time did we start today at 7
30. so how am i a 9 30 guys we started
twice a week once or twice a week the
podcast the podcast i got to give it to
you
ever since you started math so ever
since you started working here we got
you coming here at 7 30. and
that's a big deal for florida pat you
know you know
i tell people from new york all the time
if you come down to florida
and you keep that new york mentality
that hustle that you're going to kill
the world yeah because everyone in
florida i'm sleeping in i might go to
the beach today i'm hungover
i was on a yacht yesterday or you
actually were on a yacht yeah
i was hungover yesterday that's what i'm
saying like yesterday was rough
now i'm back in it but yeah you
understand like i totally get it am i
wrong on that or am i
you are so so let's go back to so trump
was a hard-working guy who expected his
people to also work hard
yes what did you learn from working
because when you work with somebody like
that for five to six years you're going
to walk away
picking up a lot of stuff what were some
of the things you took away from working
with them
a few things but number one was i
remember when i first got there in the
office there was a plaque that says
start from the end
and it took me a few seconds to
understand what that truly means but
he is always like get to the point and
he
never had the time to listen how you got
to a certain point it was just like
start from the end
[Laughter]
you know what so this is a recording
they made because adam will go and say
some stuff and i'll say what's your
point
and then we got a button yeah now we got
a button for it so he would say get to
the point
get to the point and it trains you
how to think differently and that's what
happened to me
um i immediately get to the point and
then it would be like what's your
suggestion
because coming with problems to him was
not
optimal come with what's your point
and what do you suggest another thing
that i learned to like figure it out
which is if you're tasked
with discerning for me it was trump
international
i worked with a company called bayrock
um
if you were tasked with figuring out
who's going to be your target market for
trump so
how do you get highest price per square
foot and everything had to be the
highest the best
you know the most glamorous and
everything so um you would go
into this process of what's it gonna
take and the standards were so
high that you knew if you just you know
come up with a little report and he
hated reports
you would have to tell him you know it's
the russians who will want to pay the
highest price per square foot
why not because of the location but
because of the brand this is what you
need to do with the brand so
um it was really interesting
for me at least coming from venture
capital
to real estate development and real
estate marketing in particular
how to understand to maximize the value
of a brand
to achieve maximum price per square foot
interesting
and the other thing was which i think
translated subsequently to his political
um arena was no your know your people
know your
um audience and if you
tried to target very specific audience
who
already loved the brand you just needed
to focus on them you didn't have to
worry about
trying to sell to someone else so
specific niche work on a niche that you
had
very riches in the niches you know the
whole um okay
yeah so those those were like some of
the the big big lessons and
and the other one was always beyond you
know i
i used to work from whenever i woke up
didn't even have time to train you get
ready you could get to the office you
work
uh you go to grab a bite at like six
o'clock
and oftentimes he would pop in
at like 10 30 to the office to see who's
still there night
at night and um i remember
i remember one night in particular i was
really tired i was working on a project
in phoenix so
i had taken the red eye and i was at the
office it was like 10 o'clock
i was exhausted and um
you know just kind of okay let me just
finish this
and he came by the office and we're all
like okay um
he's like you don't have makeup like why
do you look so
tired and i'm like well i've been you
know
working hard he's like get it together
finish
and go home wow so like disrespectfully
or no
it wasn't even disrespectful it was like
just an observation i didn't take it
disrespectfully but it was like
you always had to be on think about it
think about it so just so you know he
got his work ethic and his hustle from
his dad
but he got a swag from his mom his mom
was always on
and his mom always had the expectation
that you gotta like
the suave you know the swagger was a mom
thing i don't know if you've seen his
mom's hair
you know hair do what it looked like her
she had like a bouffant
yeah like pretty much so if you look at
that that's a great word
just saying well think about it have you
ever seen him
not look put together yes
when there's a lot of photos of him
looking sloppy
when when have you seen sloppy sloppy
dogs when have you seen him being sloppy
you don't see it if there is photos it's
because there's billions of photos but
the guy is pretty much
he's always suited and voted and you've
got a tan and shall we get it did you
ever see him negotiate or no did you
ever actually witness them negotiating
yes uh what was a style
uh the same what you've seen in the
white house i mean he's really like just
get it done he doesn't care how you get
it done um
very intimidating like i honestly i've
never seen him smile
during those five years so that's you
know he's very very serious
very intimidating and he would listen
but he would only listen to people he
trusts
so people who are in his inner circle
including his children
got it and did the people that were in
his inner circle did they stay there for
a long time or would they
churn and burn kind of like politics no
okay so on the business side they would
stay with them for a long time on the
business side
from his assistants to people who worked
for him were there for decades
got it last question for you about him
driving how did he drive people like you
know
uh uh there's different ways people
drive their teammates their staff their
sales people what was his style
um i would say fear-based in a way
yes because he would have really high
expectations so
if you fall beneath whatever that high
standard is
it's like you don't belong there so
it not as many carrots in that
you know he thought that
people should pay him to work for him in
a way
so many people
stay there for quite a long time because
once you're in that inner
circle there's the you know material and
financial
benefit do people make money working
with them like if you
stay with them long term you're going to
make money yes so you have to get
through a
certain threshold and certain point in
order to to make money so
i don't think um it's just the
environment was really stressful it was
very competitive
um but i think i learned a lot from it
and for me like i'm not afraid i lived
through a war so
unless someone has a gun to my head i'm
not afraid of you
um do you kind of need to have that
thick skin to even be in that
organization
absolutely like if you're not really
ready for criticism or to work hard like
that's not the place you should correct
got it correct um question
seems like you had a beneficial
experience there were some pros and cons
and you worked hard
and but overall it was a net positive
right and you've
worked pretty closely with him i mean
you're saying you'd be in the office
working at 10 p.m and he'd
show up and you interacted with him um
but you're also an immigrant you know
you live in new york city like
you have clearly a love for diversity
and inclusion and all that stuff
how much how shocking was it when you
saw the switch from businessman donald
trump to
politician donald trump you're like oh i
can see that or you're like whoa
i don't even recognize this guy where do
you where'd you go with that
that's a really great question because
someone who's seen
the business persona for all that time
when i saw the political persona i was
not shocked at all
and i actually knew how he is and that
he would polarize
the country that was very obvious
because um
he has very strong very clear like set
of
values what's important to him and how
he is and how he thinks so
if you know how he thinks you know how
he's going to act
in whatever arena he's in so um
i it was really difficult for me that
yes my experience
working there was a net positive but
as an immigrant as a woman it was really
tough for me to see
um some of the statements not some many
statements that he's made and even
what's happened in the capital and
you know but it's not shocking to me
because he steers the pot
he likes that yeah he enjoys that
he i i'm not surprised either i mean i i
you just watch him at apprentice he
steers the pot his entire career is
about to steer in the pot like what do
you expect him to do he's gonna continue
steering a pod um but you know kudos to
you
for your story to go from bosnia to come
to new york to work for trump
organization five to six years to come
over here
after your father passed you've
experienced all this different mess and
you come and
you see what's going on with america
right now sonata how much do you
love america i'm curious i can answer
that for mine but i want to hear from
you how much do you love america from
your perspective
i love it what do you love about it what
do you love about it i love the freedom
okay i love the freedom of speech
um i love the fact that you can be an
immigrant you can be a woman you can
speak with an accent but not think
with one and make it in this country you
can be an entrepreneur
i love that what does that mean speak
with an accent but not think with one
i i say that because i've never heard
that before you know you get
underestimated when you speak with an
accent that's at least what i've
experienced
and i i joke about it and i heard that
from a good friend of mine who's cuban
and i i really took that on it means
that don't underestimate me
i like it there's some people here with
an accent and a third one that can do
any accent
her and i have an accent we give you an
accent you do a german accent for us
isn't that crazy i tell you um
do you want me to do accents but don't
forget we also have other accent boy
here that's that's a bruno accident yeah
that's
that's like my gay german bruno thing
going on that's a very nice question
actually speaks uh with a thick
norwegian accent but he fakes it because
he wants to
well he feels like an american let me
hear some norwegian
oh my gosh some norwegian or a norwegian
accent
all the above the accent uh i is from
norway i moved to florida
and now i live here well you can do it
good for you
no it's that's how they speak no no
that's that's i think that's that's if
bruno were from norway yes
then she just she just called you out
bro by the way guys
shout out to kai he's talent he's behind
the scenes
let's just wrap this up since we're on
the topic because i'm curious by the way
somebody's asking a question here
daniel estacio i'm going to get your
question here matter of fact i'll just
ask her right now
her advice to florida realtor and her
favorite books
for realtors wow advice to florida
realtors
is give it your all
it's it's a crazy time and i think just
work really really hard right now
and be prepared save all your money
because we don't know how long this is
going to be here you say save that money
save that money no seriously so so work
because you don't know how long this is
going to last
yeah i think that's very good times may
not last forever i think this is very
good council so
save like you've never said before in
today's economy absolutely
some some people love to spend when when
the money is there but i just say
save all your money be very be very
very careful how you plan for your
future because
you know nothing lasts forever it's
crazy i'm buying a house right now and i
know i'm not buying at the best market
and i know that what does that feel like
knowing they're buying at the top of
them
but i know i like we just had a
conversation right off
off camera about you know whether you
buy structure you buy land all this
other stuff and
we have a good team i think we're pretty
clear on what we're looking for i think
everybody is managing expectation well
and we will see what's going to be taken
let me ask another one last question
just before because i don't know
no no just on real estate in general so
take off your
25 million dollar hat and put back on
your 700
000 hat right you said that's okay so
what advice do you have for our audience
who are
you know maybe they're buying a first
time home and you know maybe they're not
in my i mean maybe they're anywhere just
you know we talked about the list who
should be buying a place right now who
and who should be like look
maybe you're renting like give advice to
the half a million dollar buyer
million dollar buyer real quick not the
25 million dollar buyer absolutely
that's
that's a really good question in that
you know most people
feel that real estate is their highest
asset right like the highest valued
asset so when you're
making that big decision it's a very
emotional decision not just financial
i would say be logical not as emotional
about your purchase um look for
off-market opportunities
that's a big one because most people
just look what's on the market right now
use your resources your connections your
you know people you know to look for
things that are not even on the market
um because there are you know things
change unfortunately in our business you
know divorce is one of the major reasons
for people to
want to change their home situation so
i would say regardless of the price
range but 700
000 definitely finance because the rates
are so low
look for good opportunities knowing that
it's it's about the value so if you
decide to sell in three five seven or
ten years that you're going to be able
to sell your property and not regret
your decision
when you say three five seven years do
you is there a certain amount of time
that if you buy a house
you're not selling for the next x amount
of years is there sort of a rule of
thumb
um most people believe believe it or not
keep it for about seven years
that's the average but a lot of people
come and tell me oh this is my forever
home i'm going to put a fortune into it
and i'm like
don't do that because most forever homes
are not forever don't get too emotional
don't get tired stay logical i couldn't
so nine homes in
11 years like if you think about him
that's how many homes you've lived in
first of all crazy like whatever we buy
next i already know it's not like you
know
she's listening right now babe i just
want you guys
brace for impact because something's
gonna happen next five ten years that
we're gonna say let's go look at xyz
but let's talk about uh cpac
trump's speech okay what he's and i'm
not talking about cruz
or any of the other guys matt gates i'm
specifically
focusing on trump's speech what was your
biggest takeaway from what he said at
the cpac
curious me to start this the first time
he came out so why don't you take the
lead
so uh obviously he did his greatest hits
you know joe biden's the worst president
we've ever seen in the first month
and yeah the radical left and by the way
the country has seems to be doing okay
for the last month or two since biden's
like
the whole like the country's gonna fall
apart and the the communists are taking
over i've
pretty much enjoyed life for the last 30
60 days
sort of stress-free stress it was a
little insurrection at the capitol but
who's you know paying attention to that
but the thing that stuck out to me the
most wasn't so much the greatest hits
wasn't the talking about
how horrible sleepy joe is it's the
specific
singling out of any republican
who dared to cross him like if you
didn't
pray to the golden calf of donald trump
he came after you
uh liz cheney um the the guy in uh
he's very outspoken adam someone help me
out here adam
he's in chicago congressman adam kenna
kenowitz i forget his last name kai you
got a name for me
adam sumpton chicago congressman uh
illinois congressman
awesome guy um all those guys he's
specifically saying
if you voted not lock and step with
trump and you voted to impeach him
or did anything he is coming after you
yeah adam kinzinger sorry i knew he was
adam k
um who doesn't do that though i'm
curious like you tell me
what politician or president doesn't
come after the person it doesn't
call them out by name and singles them
out and
you know so this guy at least is being
truthful about
who so so the mistake on his is he
publicly shares his strength i don't i
don't i don't
but i just want you to know in the world
and this is not an out i'll take shots
at the areas that he
doesn't but you name me one politician
that's not going to remember that
you you tell me obama wouldn't want to
come back after trump to make sure he
didn't get reelected
you you mean to tell me a bush didn't go
come back after you mean to tell me none
of that none of those guys i see your
point i think you're right
clearly that's in their mind but what we
are witnessing
is the oral vindictiveness of this man
like i'm not saying behind closed doors
buddy that's probably the people
well i agree the james baker book okay
the james baker book i don't know if you
know who james baker is yeah
long-time republican
he's the genius behind the genius he was
logical right he was not the emotional
guy he was a logical guy
let me tell you everything when you go
into politics
if you don't know how to play dirty you
ever watch these guys you're like
you know what a sweet man mike huckabee
is like you know it's a sweet man you
know
his daughter couldn't anyone ever said
that yeah he's a sweet but how come you
know how come he can how come he didn't
run for how come he couldn't win it
you look at some of these other ben
carson what a sweetheart of a man
okay how come he didn't win george w
bush sweetheart no george was not out of
sweda he's trained by
prescott grandfather who was a senator
he was trained by
father cia listen there's training when
you have those kinds of people there's
low key
what i'm trying to tell you is there's
levels to the game the lower level you
are the more peaceful sweet it is the
higher you go
you realize how dirty of a game it is
and if you show any kind of weakness
look flip it if trump doesn't come out
strong
what do you think they're going to do to
him for the rest of his life if trump
comes out and is quiet like a nixon what
do they do for the rest of his life
i mean they're going to come after him
regardless for everything he's done so i
mean trump is who he is it's baked in
the cake he ain't changing
here here's my prediction my prediction
the donald trump of 2015 2016
is officially gone he has no like his
highest approval ratings ever
would never reach 50 percent he is now
baked in the cake the 30
of the of their country or you know the
gop is fractured we talk about the
the democrats having issues with the
socialists in the left the moderates
it is a clear fracture in the republican
party you're either with trump or
against them if you're just a normal
conservative
you know george will mitt romney george
bush type republican and there's
tens of millions of people like that
you're on one side of the aisle if
you're a mega
trump you know may you know that whole
vibe you're with trump like you if trump
said i'm starting my own party which by
the way he said he wouldn't do
but if he said i'm starting my own party
they're going with trumpism but he
didn't say i'm starting my own party so
i never do that
so there's a major fracture in the gop
and what we've learned
in 2020 in this election unless you
coalesce and come together as a party as
a unit as a
full-on just cohesive unit you're not
winning a general election
sorry you could play to your base yeah
all you want buddy you ain't winning the
general election so
keep doing that keep you know fracture
uh fracturalizing the
the adam kinzingers and the liz cheney's
of the world and the
lisa murkowskis and the susan collins
keep going after them
clear division of the gop and i don't
think he has any shot
of winning the actual presidency if he
does run again in 2024
but he'll clearly be the nominee if he
wants that he'll clearly be the nominee
clearly be the nominee nobody get his
ass kicked even by a
dementia sleepy joe that's my prediction
what are your thoughts on cpac
on to you though i know but yeah he he's
he's lost
all momentum from did you did you
bringing the country together
i thought it was expected so knowing his
personality he
he's very uh vindictive
and he is very firm in how he thinks
things should be and in this
you're either for him or you're against
him i know that
and and i i think there is a
a huge majority of the republican base
that is exactly what you're talking
about it's it's much more
mainstream if you will and more liberal
in
in certain ways that i think is going to
be
left out but if he's still
interested in running which i think he
will be in four years i do believe he's
going to run again
and a lot of people who were upset about
what happened during the capital
insurrection
will have to decide which way they want
to go because there's so many
republicans who voted for donald trump
not because they love or support what he
stands for
but because they want to vote republican
for lower taxes and
you know different lifestyle right less
regulation
um i think he's going to run um i think
he's going to continue to do exactly
what you talked about and
you know you asked me what i love about
this country it's freedom of speech
but he's shown some authoritarian traits
that make it more uncomfortable for
people like liz cheney to say
exactly what she wants to say so that's
the part that i don't like because
i grew up in a socialist country where
you can't speak your mind
i think in this country we all came
seeking freedom of speech so
with him it's going to be much more
difficult
and i think polarized as we go forward
but i do believe he's gonna run
i think um i agree with you i clearly
think he's the favorite and if you
chose to be the run in 2024
i think what he's going to do is he's
going to
just keep doing what donald does and
just
and wait until the midterms and what
he'll do is sort of dangle
um the trump card for a lack of a better
term over
anyone running in the midterms and if
you were with him he will go all
in with you and if you're against him he
will like a bat out of hell come at you
for the liz cheney's of the world the
susan collins of the murkowskis and
um you know anyone who voted against him
he will make
he will do his damnedest to make sure
they are not elected
and um the the guy kinzinger actually
was on the news
i i apologize if i forgot his name adam
kinslicker he said listen
in my district i won 65 of the vote he's
a republican
um donald won 52 percent so the mats on
my side
and that's something that stop what do
you mean oh my gosh
district against nation i mean stop so
that's who this is
as a congressman that's the winner
okay this is bigger than what would uh
everything that's okay
so let me ask you this question here
what feeling do you get
when you hear nancy pelosi speaking an
annoying grandma
okay fair enough okay would you agree
with that paul i don't want to offend
paul because i know he's a diehard
fan from california yeah so what what
feeling do you get when you hear
hillary clinton speaking smart robot
smart robot like she just repeats she's
just kind of doing you know
what what feeling do you get when barack
obama speaks the swaggy
hundred percent swaggy gordon swaggy i
love watching his energy people oh my
gosh you know
i when he when i watch his interview
with leno or
letterman or you just are like man cool
baby
cool right okay what what do you what do
you think about when you hear reagan
speaking
american icon american icon yeah but you
know you look at him you're like
you know i like this guy comedy fun all
that okay
what feeling do you get when you get joe
biden speaking
um dementia slash
empathy really he's a little slow
but he cares okay you can tell he cares
you got a big heart cool slow brain
that's how you feel when you get a joke
okay what feeling do you get when you
get
uh trump speaking nails on a chalkboard
okay now watch this yeah
that's for you yeah and about sixty
percent of the customers no no but
wait wait where i'm going with this i'm
with you i'm with you it's 75 million
people vote if you
underestimate this guy you're gonna
experience exactly what you're
experiencing 2015 2016. okay
so now flip this what do hillary clinton
lovers
feel when they hear hillary clinton
speak are there really
actual hillary clinton lovers 100 just
go to connecticut just just go there and
you'd see
she's such a sweetheart you don't
remember when she lost how bad people
were
crying when she wasn't so much that she
lost it was that donald trump became the
president no that was
that was their hero go go talk to
somebody
who loves you know a a or who hates
barack obama
when barack obama speaks what did he say
he's a terrorist he's not even american
but they'll say he's spiritual i want to
see his birth
pompous he's arrogant he's this he's
that right so
but but the party you have to think
about is your muslim
you cannot because i think this is going
to get to one area this is the one area
it's good it's only one question we have
to ask it's only one question we have to
ask
okay so it's not about whether you agree
with this guy's policies or not
everything he said was the same thing
except for one thing
except for one thing one of the things
he said he's never talked about before
he said are you noticing what joe
biden's trying to do to women
did you notice the the recent you know
thing he signed where transvestites can
compete now in any kind
what is what's gonna happen in women's
sports why are you gonna play tennis why
are you gonna play basketball why are
you gonna do this so that was a new
thing he threw in by the way it's so
controversial
that's similar to what he did five years
ago when he said what
get him out of here so now oh my gosh
we can't even talk about this no no he's
brilliant in his marketing and his
strategy
so why would he say something like that
that is a part and a base on the other
side they can say what you know
he's right okay he's right and that's
the democrats always been what
protecting all you know we're partying
for the women so that's kind of gonna
backfire there because
you know he knows how to play the the
divisive game just as good as these guys
knows how to play the devices well first
of all there's no doubt
just so you know his enemies are dirtier
than he is just so you know his
opponents are 10 times dirtier than he
is
but they're private he's public anytime
a person
publicly shares their strategies it
doesn't mean they're the dirtier one
the private one is the one that doesn't
say anything but behind closed doors is
like let me see how bad i'm going to
make your life a living kill
so he's not the dirty you agree with his
public strategy of airing the grievances
i agree you just heard a woman that
worked with her for a
high-ranking vp work with him for six
years explained to you how he is
nothing has changed for this guy to run
the way he runs things
i mean i can already see how he runs the
sales meetings i can already
visualize how you would drive a
salespeople this this the point i'm
trying to get to you
the only question we have to answer is
the following the only question we have
to answer is the following
can he win without twitter facebook and
youtube
that's it yeah if he can
he's gonna win if he cannot he ain't
gonna win
it's that simple by the way is he
permanently banned he's permanently
banned from twitter
okay youtube he's safe but when you do a
youtube interview with him
and if he even comments on saying you
know you guys know this was a rigged
election you guys
won the election fraud youtube youtube
disclaimer
to take that video down because we put
together uh not just that they're able
to take the video
down all the way well youtube said
anybody that talks about election fraud
they're taking those videos down
youtube made that announcement so he
can't go and say
you know well let me tell you something
you know they really stole this from us
et cetera et cetera how much hour 75
million
so the question we all have to answer is
not even a political question i don't
care how you feel about his uh
you know the wall 500 miles the only
question we all have to answer is can
this guy win
without twitter social media so if
you're watching this i'm curious if
you're watching this
right now we have 441 thumbs up
we have five thumbs down okay so 441
to five five thumbs down press thumbs up
if you think he can win without twitter
facebook and youtube
press thumbs down if you don't think he
can win without twitter facebook
youtube i'm curious to know what people
going to say but what do you think you
hit the nail on the head i got i got to
give you kudos for
for for injecting the actual
logical non-emotional question here at
hand
because that's exactly the scenario that
we should be asking
is can he win without
having big tech you know by his side or
at least
allowing him to vocalize his thoughts
without twitter
there is no donald trump presidency you
know
who who was it that you interviewed the
other day oliver north he said i wish
that
trump would put down the damn phone
something to that effect
without twitter um he's gonna and
without
you know a certain certain other extent
i don't know if facebook
instagram youtube if they're all banning
him from the platform
um he has two options that he's going to
either need to go with the mainstream
media
which clearly they're not a fan or he'll
need to speak
into the echo chamber that is newsmax
um parlor oan and he's just going to be
playing to his base
and one thing we've known about um the
sales game
or politics is you need to be able to
what convert
and if you're just playing to your 30 or
40 percent
good luck out there hoss you need to get
to at least 51
so i to answer your question
specifically
what's what's your point no chance
without big tech guy aside
okay do you guys agree no chance he wins
without big tech
paul do you agree without big tech
yeah he he needs to convert people okay
eric can he win without twitter facebook
youtube
definitely not and i think even with it
it's going to be hard for him okay so
that's a good so that's interesting and
that's a trump guy right there yeah and
that's a marine guy saying what he said
okay
kai can he win without twitter facebook
youtube
i think it'd be challenging especially
considering like his
track record he's not an unknown there's
a lot of people that
were initially thought hey let's give
him
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
um in the first time around but now
without that and also without tech i see
it as a very hard for him to
sonata would you come out and win i'm
with the marine
with or without it's with or without
because he just
lost the support of so many mainstream
republicans so many women
that this um hardcore
you know rhetoric i don't think it's
going to get him far because
i feel talking to so many clients and
friends
you know as as republicans a lot of them
don't want to be associated with
with proud boys with such extremist
groups and that's sort of the main um
support group now for trump yeah so
here's
here's where i'm going with this if if
you look at
the republican party like a sports team
right now and they have to draft
somebody right because that's what
you're looking at right now you are
essentially you're looking for a
top draft pick to build your team around
and you've got to have one person like
you're looking for lebron james you're
looking for a person to build a team
around not a talent like you can't build
around carmelo and win a championship
you can't build around certain people
but you can build around lebron you can
build around kobe you can build around
certain players right
[Music]
if i'm in that room and it's the 20 big
decision makers of the rnc republican
party
if you don't have a solution for twitter
facebook youtube
you better start putting it on somebody
else and by the way that's that includes
cpac
that includes a lot if you don't have
another platform where this guy can code
because we're so imagine he wants to say
something who does he call
like you know when you want to make an
announcement what do you say hey i'm
doing a you know get all the media out
here
okay cool everybody's in front of you 40
cameras
so here's what we're going to do i
noticed earlier today what happened in
new york i think it's a travesty with
cuomo the governor it's time to imp
okay you need that where is he gonna
who's he gonna call aon
is is he gonna call news who's he gonna
call him there's no right who's he gonna
no you can't even call fox
fox is not even going that direction fox
is also kind of going more center-right
fox is not going far right i mean
tucker's staying there hannity's staying
there but not everybody's staying there
right so the opinion people will but not
the news people in fox
but but it's not an audience to convert
he converted people on twitter facebook
youtube
so if the rnc gets
emotionally closed behind closed doors
by trump but they don't have a solution
for another platform for him to speak
you just have to be thinking about it is
there somebody for us to build around or
not so
i don't know i think uh i think
uh when he gives a speech and you're
listening to him you're like this is
exactly the speech that converted a lot
of people
inspired a lot of people that wanted to
do something with you good
now right after you gave that speech
what would you do 40 tweets on twitter
he can't do that right now
i think the republicans have clearly
two strategies they can embrace donald
trump
and play to their base and the people
that love trump and love everything
you're about
yeah they are gung-ho they love him love
him love him his approval ratings are
ridiculous
or they can try to convert people and
put their money behind someone like
a nikki haley who a democrat
would vote for it let me say that again
a democrat
would vote for a nikki haley would you
vote for pence
i would not vote for pence you wouldn't
vote for me no i'd like to
you know he's just he's just vanilla of
the most vanilla
vanilla of the vanilla vanilla i've ever
vanillaed if he's vanilla
what is biting i mean what do you know
he's got at least some rocky road in
there a little bit like some moose
tracks
two two no there's just two so you're
talking about converting
yeah as a as someone who votes typically
democrats
i'd vote for a nikki haley nikki haley
i'm coming out and saying a democrat
would consider doing that
if you want to win 50 and not just play
to your 30 percent base
you got to have someone like that i
think you want to have the mega crowd
good luck with trump y'all
it's not even the mega crowd i'm not
even worried about the mag of crowd i'm
worried about you having a platform i'm
not worried about the mag across
i'm worried about are you gonna be able
to get him from the big screen in front
of these things that you need
can you get in front of these things and
have tens of millions of people here if
you don't how are you gonna influence
people you're not gonna be able to
you're not
so you know the whole challenge with
libertarian well how come nobody's
paying attention to the libertarian
community libertarians have a great
argument
libertarians who was that by the way
well libertarians have a great argument
they have a great point
they have they have a great case how
come nobody converts but two three
percent
because they can't get here yeah but who
was that accent you did a good accent
you know who joe jorgensen is no
that's not the point the point is that's
the point yeah exactly
that is the point she was the leading
candidate in the last presidential
election
for libertarians and you as a woman
doesn't don't
you probably think joe is a man i did
it's a woman it's joe yeah
that's you and she would probably
identify with a lot of her philosophy
for sure yes yeah but the point is
if you don't get that forget about it i
don't care how amazing power of the
media you need it's extraordinary so and
he knows how to get it but if he doesn't
get it now with social
i i it's a different ballgame today you
got to be able to get me to hear you out
here if you don't have this it's going
to be a challenge okay
let's talk about banker walmart you guys
okay with that let's talk about banco
walmart so
why walmart could become a serious
player in banking as walmart looks to
launch a fintech startup the retailer is
turning to wall street veterans to help
into moving
into the banking world they picked up
two senior bankers from goldman sachs
omer ismail the head of goldman sachs
consumer bank and david stark
one of his top lieutenants to help lead
the retailer's
new fintech startup i don't think in
here it talks about marcus but we'll get
into that here in a minute
walmart announced earlier this year that
it was partnering with ribbit capital
the firm backing fintech startups such
as robinhood to offer financial products
for customers and employees customers
have made it very clear they want to
move more from
us in the financial services arena
president
and ceo of walmart us john furner
said in a statement walmart's current
financial service offering include the
walmart capital one credit card
the prepaid walmart money card and the
ability for people to cash
checks in stores they're saying if
walmart goes into the banking business
they
immediately become one of the biggest if
they go into that world
thoughts i think it's a very smart
strategy on their behalf
they are they've managed to become
such an important global player as it
relates not just retail
pharmacy you name it walmart
just has figured it out and i think it's
very wise for them because
if people are going there anyway most of
america shops at walmart right i mean
that's how it is i think it's a really
important place for them and and i know
the
the company ribbit capital the venture
capital firm uh they invest a lot in
cryptocurrency and like really
alternative
fintech startups and for them to partner
up with with walmart i think it's
it's baller so as well i like that i
think so
here's the question when's the last time
you the
luxury real estate guru shopped at
walmart
um i don't know six years ago
you're not going to find solano okay
i'll go to tarjay
oh you're more target than you're a
woman yeah
okay so you will not go to walmart
[Laughter]
that is the fancy term well let me tell
you my little experience
where was that this past sunday now that
i'm back here in south florida where was
i is anyone who saw my instagram
aisle seven no i was not i was on a boat
i was on a yacht shout out to my
uh my best friend keith mann and his
wife evelyn manning it was her birthday
we had a great time that was my sunday
in miami kai where did i go
every sunday when i was in addison texas
you went to walmart off of beltline
wild march sundays there was nothing
else to do
i mean i was just i had my walmart
sundays so
and and part of it was there's a
two-prong approach here
if you live in miami beach or downtown
miami there's not a walmart for miles
nowhere so when i moved into thank you
for your
by the way this guy got me my apartment
and i said go check out the vpnm over
there
and and you make that recommendation
right next to the artist thank you
i don't know if you guys were there to
witness this the day we announced we're
moving to florida you were devastated
you were dead no not back to miami let
me see walmart it felt like a very tough
conversation tough tough
but i'd go to this walmart and i was
shocked
by how cheap yeah inexpensive things
were
shocked i mean you're talking about in
florida you know you shop at publix it's
you know pretty standard
you go to whole foods or trader joe's
things are a little pricier there
like i felt like they were giving things
away at walmart okay and and slowly but
surely i started getting indoctrinated
to this walmart lifestyle
and damn uh you know things are
very cheap so then i started seeing the
types of people that are shopping
at walmart so it's very interesting to
back to this story
um walmart's current financial service
offerings include the walmart capital
one credit card
a prepaid walmart money card and the
ability for people to cash checks
in stores they are not these are not
that people are buying 25 million houses
these are types of people that maybe
make 25 000
a year so you know you're playing like
trump plays to his base
they're going after low income or even
middle-income americans and what we've
realized certainly
since the pandemic is the k-shaped
economy
the rich are getting richer they're
gobbling up 20 million dollar houses
like it's uh
gumballs but the rest of america you
know the rest of america has suffered
tremendously has suffered tremendously
in the bottoms
on the bottom half of the the k-shaped
economy so
where are they getting their financial
services from a lot of them are already
going
to walmart they're cashing their checks
they're doing you know
their prepaid cards so if walmart wants
to play to their base you know the 25
of americans who have no financial
education they have no savings they have
zero credit they've got just financially
a mess
you know and a part of my brand is
helping people like this get
smarter um i think that they can be a
player in the
low income middle income america well
what does that mean does player mean top
five top three can they compete at the
top what does player mean to you yeah
i mean look you know ftm
follow the money so they're going to
need the law of large numbers
to to compete they're going to need
millions and millions and millions of
low-income americans
to say all right i'm done with bank of
america i'm done with chase you know
wells fargo screwed me over one too many
times
i'm a walmart guy now i'm a walmart gal
and
you know they're gonna would you
consider yourself a walmart like no but
wait a minute actually a serious
question your whole spiel about you go
to walmart a lot kind of hurts your game
a little bit
you never bring that up i'm very
transparent you don't go on a date
and you say hey mary good to meet you
first time by the way i was at walmart
the other day
at least he'll know that they like him i
will take them to walmart and see how
they
their selective process i will take them
on a date to walmart high end
take any serial you anything you want
baby i got you i don't know we're going
to walmart
is beautiful this time of year that's
true sure so paul's going to say
something about walmart but before you
do that
you're going to make a point question i
was going to ask you is this walmart
opens up
the banking set would you open up an
account with them zero percent chance
zero percent less than zero yeah i'm not
i'm not banking at walmart
like no like the fine not a good look by
the way
keep this piece and record it shop
shopping
watching shopping for serious [ __ ]
avocados
i got my walmart black card y'all go
ahead go ahead
i think a big part of where they can
succeed in this arena is
the bank culture and the bank industry
themselves they have a culture right
it's that
eight to five and they're not open past
five o'clock if walmart
offers because one of their big benefits
because even when i was driving
like from here to texas yeah like i
needed a couple things and i'm like
where's a walmart at and i know i can
count on them that's a good point so if
they can do that same thing in the
banking industry and be like hey i need
to go
to the bank at nine o'clock at night
i'll be let me ask you let me ask you
paul e yeah would you ch who's your bank
right now uh it's a southern call
don't say what's that people may go and
try to give you guys you want to start
banking at walmart you
if they offer what i just said if they
are more convenient because like i don't
go to the bank anymore but
i if i need an app i need an app you
would bank at walmart i would bank at
walmart
boom you don't go to the bank anymore no
what do you mean because everything you
do is online everything's online yeah
okay my bank's in california
okay fair enough so so so here's the
here's the follow-up question for you a
couple things to be thinking about
do you know 97 of america lives within
10 miles of a walmart
let me say this one more time 97 of
america
lives within 10 miles of a walmart goes
back to your point
okay do you know how many people
per year walk through a walmart walk not
not not if you walk in 19 times you
don't count us
19 times how many i'm just one time
individual yeah 200 million i was going
to say somewhere around to a couple
hundred
million 100 million but not sonata she
hasn't been there in
seven years well maybe they're gonna get
her business now but watch
out would you would you consider banking
at walmart if she hears about that's not
happening well here hear me out for a
second hear me out for a second so
first of all what is robin hood robin
hood is for what low income and middle
america that's what they're targeting
great who's goldman sachs when you think
about goldman sachs what do you think
about
high-end high i'm going to cry you need
10 million to get in if you don't have
10 million by the way they only have 400
advisors morgan merrill have 13 000 they
only have 400
and they have 400 to say we don't need
we only have 400 because we get the
cream of the crop cornell university
penn you know wharton those are the kind
of guys that we get that come to us okay
great but the two guys they recruited i
don't know if you've looked into who
these two guys are
the two guys that were recruited omar
ismail was the head of
golden consumer bank that's what you
just read that they said go
and hear david stark partner at goldman
david is the right-hand guy to omar
at goldman sachs omar led the way
because
goldman saw what was happening with
robin hood and others and acorn
so they started a branch called marcus
invest yeah
mark is to get in you only need a
thousand dollars to go into having an
account
so goldman sachs who has been the cream
of the crop you need 10 million to come
in if you don't have 10 million we're
not even doing anything with you
unless if you're part of the family they
saw the trend and they said let's go
open up marcus
to allow people to come in you answer
the questionnaire minimum investment you
need to make is what a thousand dollars
now you got an account
phenomenal idea right it's okay great
name by the way
by the way last year just the marcus
business model generated 1.2 billion
dollars in revenues
97 billion dollars deposited into
markets
let me say this one more time just last
year 1.2 billion dollars of revenues 97
billion dollars invested into
mark is last year around 2020 during the
pandemic
and this is who walmart these are the
two guys they recruited
smart so they recruited away the guys
who led
marcus to go to walmart so now they're
gonna go to walmart bring that
experience from goldman sachs they
recruited the main guys
you want to recruit they're going to
more to walmart now
97 of america lives within 10 miles 200
million people that are visiting walmart
you got all this business now you got a
banking all the locations traffic's
already coming in
you know then the question becomes who's
an ally who's an
enemy meaning who wants to see this
become a reality
who doesn't want to see this become a
reality does bfa want to see this become
a reality
does chase want to see this become a
reality do they want to see this become
a reality
who does want to see them become a
reality does a robin hood does a goldman
do d who
who is it so i think that's going to be
the battle but walmart
you know what the the number one enemy
of walmart is who
who's the number one amazon amazon's the
number one enemy
is this also going to be the first mover
where amazon next is going to want to
come up with bank
is this when all these other guys are
going to shoot you know we get all this
money that's coming and maybe we got to
play ball
and can amazon compete at the level
walmart and this is an
area where amazon cannot compete with
walmart
this is one area why is it because they
have
actual stores 97 yep
10 miles got it so i can say to you 97
of americans are within 10 miles of my
bank called the bank of walmart
that's that's very very interesting the
angle they took
if you think about it because it's what
amazon cannot directly compete
with them in a couple of thoughts um
we were joking about the walmart thing
and we talked about goldman sachs and
marcus
if from an optic standpoint and a
branding standpoint
and pr standpoint you can't be bank of
walmart
you got to come up with you know a
fancier name
or a marcus type of a thing for it to be
a little more palatable
if you're going to convert people like
if you're already banking at walmart and
you're cashing your checks there you're
going to frickin walmart whatever but if
they come up with a
you know an attractive name and it's
whatever fair enough you know people
will will be a little more opt to go
there that's number one
number two uh you brought up amazon you
know if we learned anything from
jack ma's ant group what was the what's
their whole company that they're doing
over there uh
the the ant group and alibaba the whole
fintech like you're banking you're
shopping you got your id
you got your driver's license you got
your credit card you've got every
financial service tool boom on your
phone
okay so there's a model out there for
amazon
to potentially emulate and obviously
walmart is kind of playing in that
and that thing but to paul's point does
it really matter that you live
near your bank because banking is online
anyways how often do you go
into your bank anyway so i get it that
it's cool to live
near a bank maybe you know where you're
shopping don't forget how often do you
need to do that you are rich to middle
america adam don't forget who you are
you you may not be selling 25 million
dollar homes but
you're you still made your money it's
not like you're making 50 000
urine you don't know what it is to be
50k right now you don't know
the level of trust like you know how i
don't know if you guys got family where
they say
oh i don't trust a you know online i
like to go to a physical but there's
still
people like that that want to go to a
place and it's typically folks that make
35 45 55 000 that's their market so
they're targeting their own they're not
targeting you they're not targeting you
they're not targeting
but they are targeting that so yes i
think there's one interesting thing as
well that you're not necessar that you
guys haven't brought up at least
uh walmart has 4 700 locations
in america i mean you overnight they can
have 4
700 locations with a bank imagine you
know how apple
also did their card where you get
certain cash back you get certain
discounts and stuff like that imagine if
walmart does that where you get two
percent cash back on
on groceries imagine the 200 million
people that go
shopping there i automatically agree 10
20 30 40 50 percent overnight can switch
over
and just have an extra car it's it's the
it's the look look at the way they did
good for them man good
you know i'd love to see walmart and
amazon
do you want to say that i just want to
see that i want to see if i want to see
a heavyweight match up because
think about think about when amazon
bought
whole foods you're like what is that
tell you thinking
yeah and and people are like wow you
know it's just not not really a good
move it's just
you know it's like yeah okay okay buddy
so then emma's if you're an amazon are
you an amazon prime member
yes can you please put in your number
matter of fact just go to your app
and show the thing qr code boom oh you
just got a nine dollar discount
i paid 99 bucks for prime and wow
okay so now you're going back to whole
foods they charge
20 percent more than a regular place but
you feel healthier when you buy it whole
foods so funny same thing
they feel healthy paycheck guy's a
genius the guy who set it up by the way
so i don't know i i i kind of think this
could be very interesting
and i don't think amazon could compete
directly with these guys
not in this area may i make one more
point which is
in the past the american dream was
owning a home right
now the american dream is being an
investor so even if you look
at what happened a few weeks ago with
gamestop a lot of these
investors and and people who are part of
robin hood
they're all they're students they're you
know
people who make whatever they make and
they want to feel like they're part of
that american dream
which so i think there is this huge
transformation and evolution of what it
means to be
successful in this country and if you
feel like you're part of the
whatever it looks like be it you know
invest
investment in stock market and now
walmart i think this is
incredible because like you said they
have a captive audience they have
millions they probably have details of
every single american citizen data you
think about the data
so the data is that's that's where the
power is you have captive audience so
how do you just
smartly and strategically incorporate a
whole new
um segment of of business i wonder if
they sat there and they said what can we
do that amazon can't do
i wonder if that was the board meeting
of course it was what can we do
like you know the whole blue ocean
strategy concept is you're going to
compete with somebody not directly in an
area that they're weak and i wonder if
they sat there
and the brains in that board was what's
the one thing they cannot do
banking let's go into it so if walmart
now you're buying your loan
from walmart you buy a house you get
your loan 300 000 loan from walmart
times
millions i mean that's that can really
scale that can really scale
and and you know as far as the name goes
i mean walmart's used to have a new name
sam's club you know they have you know
they don't
sam's club is owned by walmart sam
walton
sam's the founder sam's club sam walton
sam's club yeah okay
they could come out with a new name it's
not a big deal you were going to say
something if you look at it the way
apple has their ecosystem of the apps
the app store kind of how everything is
kept within it
imagine how walmart can do that with
with banking as well i mean then you're
just controlling
i i am a lot of forward to this
heavyweight oh this could get
so interesting so interesting one thing
i've definitely
realized slash learned about you you
you light up when you think about
competition oh yeah when you think of
walmart versus amazon you like genuinely
like
oh yeah baby let's get that competition
love it
of course i love you you want to compete
the night connor lost to
podiura i'm like what you know because
we wanted to see a khabib fight yeah
of course you want to see a fight like
that but this you realize this is the
ultimate heavyweight
yeah yeah yeah this is trillion dollar
companies going up against each other
well it's like facebook and apple kind
of
talking smack getting into it that's
heavyweight stuff i don't think so
i don't think so i don't think so
because facebook and apple no
okay okay let me oh my gosh adam i can't
believe you went over there
so so i went there watch this year watch
this yesterday okay
what percentage of facebook's revenue
comes from ads don't say it
what do you know it already well we
talked about okay so what is it it's
like 98
98 yeah okay crazy
apple's revenue 98 doesn't come from one
product
so what amazon and walmart are playing
they're trying to go dominate other
facebook is not playing that game
facebook's playing the
ad game facebook's competition is nbc
cnn fox data data it's you know what i'm
trying to
all the game they're playing is you're
gonna come
advertise and put your commercials with
me you're gonna come spend your ads with
me not with these other schmucks because
people are on this year
they're no longer watching so facebook's
a complete different animal yeah
and by the way to them to that to their
strength they're in a position that
they're probably the hardest to directly
compete with facebook's not easy to
directly compete with
who's going to directly compete google
plus try to come out with a social media
site how long did how many guys actually
posted more than five things on google
plus
never even heard of it
google plus came out it was their
facebook they got 50 million subscribers
a month one they said they're going to
blow up they're going to be facebook
i never once posted on instagram when
when did that when was here what year
was that's the point yeah i never heard
of it
you weren't that's like me and facebook
walmart exactly
exactly that's a lot i i know
i know uh google plus like sonata knows
joe jorgensen i just i don't
okay what so so so that guy so here's a
question for everybody that's watching
if you think if you think bank of
walmart
will compete thumbs up if you think
i don't think they're going to compete
with bank of america and all the other
guys thumbs down i'm curious we got 636
to 34.
by the way the last one i asked the
question can trump win without
yeah uh it was three to one which means
three people said he still can
one said he cannot so it's interesting
to see what the staff we know some of
the people in our audience well we'll
see what's going on i agree
so regardless okay so are you bottom
line is are you
rooting for walmart to beat amazon i'd
say compete
beat i i am rooting for walmart to
make the banking industry uncomfortable
i am rooting for walmart to make amazon
uncomfortable because you know who wins
here
the consumer baby that's why you love
capitalism yeah
yeah that's why you love capitalism
because it works it's not about you it's
about the consumer when
at the end of the day you win at the end
of the day it's interesting how you
light up when you talk about these kind
of things there's something in your
bones that this is in your dna
capitalism competition well you know
taking over here you have a top realtor
who worked for a capitalist left
socialistic communistic nation to come
to us you got a guy like me who lived in
iran
what do you want to call that it's not
socialistic dictate
totality fascist fascist what do you
want to call it women don't have any
freedom you can't vote
girls get married at 13 years old i mean
that's iran's laws it's what you're
talking about and
we leave we go to germany we come here
and then you can build the kind of life
that you got here
yeah capitalism works you work for a
capitalist
you work for a capitalist i work for a
capitalist we're all capitalists
everybody every i my commission that
comes from insurance companies comes
from because somebody started a business
that's a capitalist capitalism
the only way the socialism argument
exists is because of a capitalist
only way if there is no capitalism there
is no other argument no other isms
if it wasn't because of capitalism no
isms comes
first the first ism that comes is what
capitalism no other ism you need money
to be able to spend the money
and the capitalists know how to make the
money so others can come out with their
own individual
isms whatever those isms may be right so
yes i'm a die-hard capitalist and i will
keep saying that for the rest of my life
and i know if it offends you i know you
get very uh uh frustrated when i do so
boy community we're gonna be alright yes
i have a community i know you're getting
emotional i love capitalism
i just don't like uh authoritarianism no
authoritarianism well i don't like crony
what i don't like i'm not a fan of that
part because that's not a great
equalizer okay
so let's talk about buffett is it okay
if we talk about another capital it's
fair to say that warren buffett
is one of the greatest capitalists of us
of our era a democrat
a a independent
read his book i don't know if you've
ever read his book you ever read his uh
what is that one book uh uh snow huh
snowball effect
you ever read it it's a few thousand
pages it's every week every year
remember that's his new sunday
forget about the yachts in south beach
i'm reading his annual letters every
week reading the book it's actually by
the way it's actually
if you don't read it listen to the
audiobook okay
and i'm recommending this to everybody
you will learn
so much about how he became who he is
today personal life
marriage how he managed it what happened
to his wife at the end
you know his parents the influence of
his parents republican party democratic
party how he got involved
all of it fascinating anybody could you
sell that guy a 25 million dollar house
he still lives in his name no
you could house in omaha that he's lived
in for like 50 years he's a different
type of a capitalist where
you have to save your money and and be
smart what you do with it i like that
guy he's kind of like i like that guy
he's kind of like
that's more you know that he he eats
mcdonald's every day uh
for breakfast and the market whole foods
would have been better for him but
you know he's just 90 he's 90 and he's
doing great
and he drinks he says what he drinks
eight to eight coco coca-cola's a day
is what he drinks i think he's trying to
get everybody else to drink eight
because but
he's the biggest shareholder so let's
talk about buffer it's got a few
different things that we've got to cover
so let's try to get all of this first
one is warren buffett says fixed income
investors face bleak future
despite the recent sell-off that send
treasury yields to their highest point
in a year
as high as 1.6 bonds remain unappealing
and should be avoided legendary investor
warren buffett says
in his annual letter in berkshire
hathaway shareholders on saturday bonds
are not the place to be in these days he
added in certain large and important
countries
such as germany and japan investors earn
a negative return on trillions of
dollars of sovereign debt let me read
that one more time
he said in certain large and important
countries such as germany and japan
investors earn a negative return on
trillions of dollars of debt
fixed income investors worldwide whether
pension funds insurance companies or
retirees face a bleak future
buffett noted that the income available
from a 10-year us treasury bond at the
end of 2020 was 0.93
which has fallen 94 from 15.8 percent
in 1980 what's a bad example to use
because 1981 is jimmy carter but
typically
three to five percent is what she had
it's still a big drop off that we've had
so
thoughts on what he said about fixed
income
i actually agree with agree with him
he's looking for the highest growth
and that's why he bought
back all these berkshire hathaway shares
right
i i think with fixed income um
it's really good when
the returns are great and you feel
comfortable and safe
when the economy goes down but in time
of such
extraordinary growth why would you want
to do that
i would agree with that but i think
there's an area that's the concern i'm
curious to know
what are your thoughts about uh well i
mean i talk to a lot of millennials
about investing especially in the stock
market i'm a
big fan of investing in the stock market
you know and diversify and having some
crypto in your portfolio
and the conventional wisdom is have your
age in stocks and or bonds and kind of
have like if you're 30 years old have 70
stocks 30 bonds if you're 80 years old
bonds 20 stocks that's sort of the
conventional wisdom but at this point
you know unless you're 80 and you're not
taking on any risk why would you be in
any bonds at this point i know like
anything so
when you have someone like uh warren
buffett even saying like
what the hell are you doing in bonds uh
you know i try to
put the people first and and make
recommendations to them
you need to be in the stock market i
mean obviously if you're in the you're
looking for a house and you want to
invest
awesome but you need to be in the
equities
stock he's he's talking about what is
his concern about not being a fixed
income because fixed income's not going
away it's not like it's going to be
going away but
here's what you're looking at to your
note right now if you got a two-year
treasury what is it
yeah i mean if you've got a five-year is
0.728
if you got a 10-year note is 1.44 it's
gonna take 50 years for your money to
double so i put a hundred thousand
dollars in there 50 years from now i'm
92.
yeah it's going to be 200 000 dollars
why not just keep it in cash
what's the point well no it's not even
cash cash if you don't know what you're
doing this is still better than if you
stay in cash
better but not liquid and you're what's
the point you don't
know what you're doing it's still better
but watch the third year yeah a 30-year
treasury note
30-year yeah 2.2 percent why
so so the challenge isn't that you know
whether you believe it or not i actually
think these things are going to go up in
the next few years
i think these numbers are going to go
well they can't go down no
they could go down i think they're going
to go up the next three to five years
because uh the market is going to take a
hit when it does bonds are going to come
back up
but the concern is the following okay so
if i put 30-year note at 2.2 percent
you know rule of 72 30 76 72 divided by
2 is what
36 it's 2.2 so it's 30 32 years
gold right now 1700 bucks do you think
gold is going to double in the next 30
years
double double in price 30 years yes do
you think it's going to be 3 500
an ounce 30 years from now possibly
possibly do you think it could you know
go maybe not double go to
you know seven thousand dollars
announced 30 years from now 30
years from now gold we don't create more
gold gold is gold
do you think the price in ounce of gold
will be 7
000 30 years from now i don't i mean i i
i with a limited supply and and high
demand then
possibly yes i mean this is this is the
the point i'm trying to make to you is
like
two percent on a third year who the hell
in their right minds would
lock in their money for 30 years right
now at 2.2 percent who's doing that
institutional investors
investors pension funds yeah i mean take
a little risk
i mean what are you about 200 over 30.
but i tell you depending on the age
bracket and where you're at with your
risk tolerance say you're dealing with
somebody that's 60 years old
i don't even know if a 60 yeah i would
probably be more focused on having a
fixed income fund to put money into
because
i actually think it's going to go up in
the next few years i don't think these
numbers are going to stay
i don't think buffett is saying it hey
it's a bad time to be in of course it's
a bad time to be in but i think he's
going to be in three years from now
it depends like i'm not thinking of
institutional investors i'm just
thinking of
you know i'm a person and i'm looking to
invest like that's what i'm you know
so if you're looking to for growth and
you're
30 years old there's zero percent reason
you should be in bonds at this point
like
i can't think of a reason i mean maybe
there's some out there if you're
conservative what have you but if you've
made your money like susie orman who's a
pretty famous
financial she's saying that she's all in
bonds and they're like well
why the hell would you be in bonds she's
like look i've made my millions
why do i want to have any risk
whatsoever 70 years old
it becomes about wealth prices yeah i
just can't i'm keeping my money i'm good
but if you're looking to like for me i'm
in you know growth strategy i want
you know returns and i want my million
to go to five million and yada yada
equities stocks risk bitcoin commodities
but
not bonds so depends where you're at so
the older and more conservative you are
sure stick to bonds but if you're
looking for growth
no that's the the the th this is not
working well so let's talk about the
buy-back so he's buying back his shares
okay and he's talking about america is
the greatest country in the world
there's
never been a better time to be in
america you know etc etc
what are your thoughts when he is buying
back his own shares and we're not
talking about like a little bit 25
billion dollars of his own shares
they're buying back
well you talked about where his mindset
was this he's clearly
bullish on his own company and he thinks
that the stock is low
and if he's gonna how do you as an
investor process
when buffett says don't worry about
buying my share i'm gonna buy 25 billion
of it how do you
process him doing that he believes in
his company and he believes in america
and i mean
anytime here's something i'll say about
buffing anytime
not that i'm a doubting america anytime
i'm just like
feeling a little uneasy with what's
going on in the world
there is something really cool about
being reassured by warren buffett
bet on america don't bet against america
like there is something just that
reminder
is pretty cool you know you yeah being
from bosnia hearing things like that
like what how does that make you feel
when you're here
buffett just being like he's the
pre-eminent
thought leader as it relates to
investments and
finances and knowing yes he made
his money here right but
he is just so wise and you know
90 at 90 years of age he's seen it all
pretty much
um i i'm the same way like i want to
know what his thoughts are and what he's
doing
to gauge and look at the crystal ball
because we don't have one
where this market is going to lead us to
because it's it's even though it's so
good and so hot right now it's like
you wonder what's going to happen in
five years so looking at what he's doing
i i'm
also a big believer in in sort of if you
believe in your company
buy back your shares you know where your
money is going
um you're not gonna just put it into
treasury bonds
um but i believe in america i believe in
american business and
innovation which is something you know
however much you want to look at
um investments in in europe and
asia and there's some amazing companies
there when you look at
american innovation and technology which
is where all of the new growth is coming
from where
that's why walmart is looking at fintech
you know
you're looking at um mostly american
companies
you know the the one question i have is
the following
has uh buffett lost his ways okay
and i know it's a listen you know to say
something like that it's pretty bold
statement to go up against the guy
that's worth nearly a billion dollars to
say
kai do you have an email are you
checking 80 or no 80 billion i mean 80
billion is 80 billion
but but i'm going to show you data here
for you to look at that
uh uh uh so it's it's comparing how
berkshire hathaway is done versus s p
500 i don't know if you guys seen these
numbers or not
also regarding kind of how they're
growing so big at a certain point that
it's harder to pick investments because
you gotta pick winning stocks
essentially
yeah but you gotta see how he does
against snp if there's one person he
cannot lose to his s p 500
that is not good in his world like you
can lose to ray dalio you can lose to
anybody else you cannot lose to some
people he's such a big proponent of just
index and nothing just look at the link
i sent you that's right
that's the one as well that's the one
january that's a good one to go to
so go up right there okay can you make
that a little bit bigger yeah make that
a little bit more bigger okay so check
this out
2020 okay so the light blue
is s p 500 the dark blue is berkshire
hathaway right
kai stop look at 2020 okay s p 500
did 20 he did four percent
look at 2019 s p 500 did 35
he did 10 look at 2018
smp 500 lost say 5 he made
three percent fixed income 2017 even
match 2016 he wins look at 2015.
he lost 15 percent s p 500 made two
percent
till you 14 he wins double 13 tie game
12 tie game
11 he loses 2010 he wins 2009 he got
crushed
right 2008 about the same 2007 if you
look at
seven six he destroys them right but go
to 2000
look how he did in 2000 crushed smp5
look at 1999.
he lost right because that's the dot-com
era etc
so you know you know the the the era
of berkshire hathaway the one thing the
market is questioning is the following
look when he sold his 10 11 percent he
had in those four airlines remember when
he sold like
he owned 10 percent of united 10 percent
in america 10
and all these guys sold them right at
the beginning of the pendant bad time to
sell it because it went 10x it went 10x
six months later
so that cost them some money here so
my biggest concern is the following
when you think about uh elon musk
and tesla would you do you think tesla's
going to sell
if elon musk is no longer with us if
they keep creating their products
you think it's going to sell i think it
is because i think it's a good car
i think it's a very very good product
that they're producing
is iphone selling after steve jobs why
because it's a good what good product
mac it's a good product they produce
good product
berkshire hathaway is philosophy and
intuition
can you duplicate intuition can you
duplicate intuition
like does trump's kids have the
intuition of the father
you know does can obama teach intuition
to his kids
can elon musk teach intuition to his
four or five kids
you cannot teach intuition so berkshire
hathaway is an interesting place right
now because
90 years old listen i mean people are
sitting there saying we love this guy we
were 90 years old charlie munger is a
little older as well they did the
shareholder meeting in la for a reason
typically they do it in omaha but they
did it in l.a because of charlie munger
so they didn't do the meeting in the
typical place that they do it for
decades
right why because you couldn't travel or
well i mean it's just you know
concerns covets safer much better if we
do years old yeah i mean you understand
it right so
but the big question to ask is are they
going to be able to continuously beat s
p 500
it's not been our last few year run i
mean he had a good run in 2000s or 19
90s or 80s
but there's a difference between 80s 90s
and 2000s and today by the way he's the
biggest shareholder of apple these are
the companies they own today
uh american express biggest shareholder
apple b of a
charter communication coca-cola chevron
gm merck
moody's u.s bangkok verizon you know
you and he's very careful with
technology he barely got into apple like
he was
you know always negative about what
technology is going to do
not bullish on bitcoin yeah for example
i'll give you an idea like right now
baseball cards okay i don't know if you
guys have been following any of the
baseball cards if you want to put it up
crazy story on what happened you heard
when i sold my uh
for 1.3 million two down for two million
bucks oh my gosh
so two cards or two million dollars okay
on luka doncic's birthday go to the
other one i sent you
luka doncic he's 22 years old crazy his
rookie card just sold for 4.6 million
dollars
it's the second most expensive card ever
sold he's never won a championship he's
never won an mvp
he's 22 years old he even set himself in
an interview
i'd like to own some of my own cards
because millions are being made
he doesn't make money on these cards he
just got a contract pay me some of these
millions of dollars right
go lower to show the card what it looks
like do you have the picture of the card
if you go up it's uh okay they don't
have it here
go to the other one go to no the other
one i sent you
this guy right here he bought mickey
mantle's psa 10 card for
five point two million dollars look at
the top
5.2 million dollars guys holding the
card right there wow who is this guy how
does he have five million bucks i mean
he paid 5.2 million dollars for this car
we need to sell him a luxury
house asap so watch what happens here
watch what happens here go to
nba top shot okay i don't know if you
guys have been following this or not
okay so look at the reaction of
everybody
okay people have spent more than 230
million dollars
buying and trading digital collectibles
on nba
highlights a recent highlight okay go on
youtube to show one of the highlights
it's a video you buy for three hundred
thousand dollars
okay yes exactly let me just show you a
card
type in nba highlights uh nft uh uh
uh uh put lebron just put lebron yellow
bronze let's see if it shows
uh one of them just sold for 300 okay
say the same thing you typed and put it
in google same thing you typed and put
it in google okay and i'm going to get
to my buffet point here because it has
to do
230 000 no there's one that i just sold
for oh right there
click on the second one lebron james
highlight video
just sold for 270 000
guys it's a six second video
go down it's a six second video okay if
they have the video to show go a little
lower let's see if they got it you guys
got to see this here
go lower okay they don't have it anyways
it's a
six second video of him uh duncan you
buy it you own the crypto
highlight for 230 000 dollars
230 million dollars has already been put
into this this is branch bank you know
they just got started
so it's not cryptocurrency it's crypto
collectible
cards and videos okay so now watch this
i'm being interviewed guys ask me a
question because you know it's a
collectible
genius guy and this last week i spoke to
guys that run
uh the biggest auction and a new thing
called rally put
rally rd i think it's a rally rd you can
officially buy
stocks of cards go to rally rd i think
this is the one
you buy stocks of cards i like this they
bought my wayne gretzky card they bought
it
for 720 000 one of them they have it on
there right now for eight hundred
thousand dollars you can buy a share
for 12 bucks love it oh my god love it
genius idea yes okay and by the way they
don't just do it with cards
they do with paintings they do with
artwork they do it he's going to come in
now next month we'll have a conversation
with something
rally genius idea rally is a platform
for buying and selling
equity shares in collectibles
collectibles assets
any kind of collectibles artwork
painting
genius if you're like look i'm not
trying to drop 200 grand on a baseball
card
sure cool put in 10 grand and i'll you
get a portion of a zion williams
exactly that's exactly what it is so now
you're in advertising
um things that only the super rich used
to have access to
exactly artwork you gotta i own two
percent of a picasso
which what you just said is exactly how
they sell it
what you just said exactly how they sell
it right so now
what does this have to do with buffett
here's what it has to do with buffett
the guy asked me a question who says so
what do you think is going to go up and
what do you think is going to go down do
you think the physical cards
are going to be bigger or you think
these crypto nfd type of stuff is going
to be bigger
i said the benefit i have is i'm 42
years old
is i'm young enough to remember i'm old
enough to
know the value of cards when it was 30
years ago when we collected them and
it's emotional to me
but i'm young enough to be logical to
know this crypto
stuff that you're seeing that's
ridiculous to warren buffett it's going
to take off
this is going to take off so the
challenge with buffett is
is there an age where you hit where some
of the philosophies and the risks that
you took you no longer will take
to outgrow s p 500 i don't know
that's the challenge because remember
you're not buying a physical product
you're buying the man's mind and he's 90
and the other one is 95.
so is berkshire hathaway going to
continue growing after
buffett what do you think i think they
clearly have to have an
exit strategy or a succession plan in
place it's not like
god forbid warren buffett dies this week
they're like what do we do now
oh my god they're like our leaders are
in their 90s
they're like the the two guys and like
the muffet the muppet up in the crowd
like the old guys yeah like
they have a succession plan in place
clearly like
we're not i wouldn't overthink this i
would i would assume that they have
a plan in place and they understand that
they need to know my question though my
question is can you teach intuition
no i mean you give the example of like
tony robbins son is trying to go out
there and give speeches and you're just
like
you know sorry buddy like you know
michael jordan
exactly like i don't think don jr has
what
trump has you know maybe a little bit
eric certainly doesn't you know
ivanka maybe a little bit uh tiffany no
um wait no we'll see what baron's talk
is that but the point is you can't teach
intuition you can't teach what you're
talking about so
um but berkshire hathaway what do you
think
i think i think there's a philosophy
right
and you either have
intuition charisma your own set of
beliefs
and values and experiences and people
follow you for whatever reason they want
to follow you right but
with the succession plan if a
philosophy of a company worked out for
decades based on warren buffett's
values and beliefs of investing then
you have to find someone who has a
similar philosophy
but also dares to look at new ways of
for growth opportunities such as walmart
looking into vincent and i just
i think it's extraordinary what you just
said in that
you have to be old enough to be
wise and experienced but you have to be
young enough to know that
things are changing i mean just look at
the
after the advent of google the whole
world has changed right since 2002 or
three
this is why they're saying that chamath
palapita
is sort of the new school warren buffett
you heard this analogy people are making
this analogy a lot do you know who this
is jamaat
he's pull him up maybe she's recognized
these are very successful
part small owner of uh uh or state
warriors
he was an early investor in facebook i
believe and he's he's a billionaire he's
and
and and then remember that face we're
going to sell him a 25 minute
house i get a 10 report with him we can
sell him a 40 million
no you could actually it's not a problem
and he would actually do what's his net
worth probably yeah he's a kill and a
half i think he's a he's a bill or two
billion dollar guy
is he two he's a billionaire guy what
does your net worth need to be
sonata to buy a 20 million dollar house
you need to be worth
100 million 200 million uh
like for a 20 million dollar house yeah
and in detail if someone's looking at a
20 million dollar house
like you know all right this person is
worth you know yeah you have to be
worth at least i would say 200 100
unless exactly 10x unless unless
you decide to um
have not just mortgage but like some
people use asset-based loans
to to finance if they feel very strongly
the the value of the house is gonna if
they consider it as an investment
rather than just a place so if you're
looking at a million dollar house
do you have to have a net worth of a
hundred thousand of the same rules you
need to have less a little bit
different rules yeah so it's um because
i will say huge majority i was going to
say 99 of
of people looking at ultra luxury real
estate
are all paying cash cash 25.
yeah but for people who are looking at a
million dollar property
most of them are actually looking to
finance so that's why it's so different
you only need 20
to put down rather than you know
being 10x okay so so are you optimistic
long-term berkshire hathaway or no
i'm not betting again i'm not betting
against warren buffet no no but wait a
minute i didn't say warren see how i got
all
you see how i got diplomatic i know you
did yes i am yes i am you're
you're i believe that he has uh
imparted enough wisdom and knowledge and
principles on the people that will be
taking over because i don't remember the
gentleman's name but we talked about
who the next man up was but i believe
that they
are like you said old enough to
understand
the past but young enough to to move
with the times what do you think sonata
long-term berkshire are you long
berkshire hathaway or short
i oh that's a tough one particularly
knowing what we just discussed
i'm long-term because of the sheer size
and um ability to to move through
whatever the market's going to bring and
just look at the companies that
if you're the biggest investor in apple
i'm riding with you straight up
coca-cola
and and the thing is obviously i think
it's gonna take a hit once
one or both of them passes away just
emotionally because people are gonna be
like all right i'm out
uh however he has said multiple times he
the the companies that have been chosen
in the past are such
value companies that he said like
essentially a ham sandwich can run them
because they're so
stable companies that don't require a
lot and if those are the ones they own
then i think those will stay valuable uh
long term but however the question is
will they able be able to pick
new companies like that that's where the
issue's gonna be well that's that's
that's the processor of somebody so i
you look how many things you're seeing
right now where the math makes zero
sense like the typical formula of that
was used 20 30 years ago doesn't apply
today but he was the same way during the
stock boom
what are you doing the dot-com bubble
like he he's pulled out of the
of the market because he says the market
doesn't make sense why don't you go go
to berkshire hathaway stock go to
berkshire hathaway stock history of it
let's take a look at that berkshire
hathaway stock history
it still looks very good i think it's at
350 377 000 right now
per share look at that it's gone up will
it continue
going up post buffett that's the
question that
if you want to buy one share right now
you're spending 377
wow to buy one share a share b share is
like 300 bucks but if you want to buy an
asia right now
377 thousand dollars a share 81. for
one share is 377. you gotta love that
though
hey we're not doing splits we're not
doing anything you want to share spend
that 377
and people where is that where is that
on the most expensive stocks
it's a share it's standard number one
yeah it's the most expensive
they've never done a split they've never
done it they tell you you want it spend
that 377 and then you'll be invited to
the
shareholder meeting that they're having
can you imagine but everybody that goes
there owns at least one ship
back to your point with that rally if
you want to own a percentage of a stock
and
you know there's companies out there
like stockpile and
things like that where you can you know
have um
one guy gave parts of the stock buffett
ten thousand dollars back in 1974.
this guy was a small you know the story
we were talking about that hunt that
ten thousand dollars he left it never
touched it it's worth 780 today
wow never touched the money you gotta so
you're banking
on a guy you bet on a guy but anyways
let's wrap up with the story of zlatan
okay let's talk about our
favorite guy here's zlatan lebron james
responds
to zlatan and he says there is no
because latin
initially told them do we have here what
he says or no
it's lower uh let me see what you have
to do
okay so you don't have what he said why
don't you pull up on twitter what zlatan
said and i want to
uh put up exactly what the respond is so
kai just pull up the twitter zlatan's
tweet
about uh lebron lebron
there you go i think it was an interview
in um l.a times i think
you're right i think yeah you are right
it's just why don't you set the stage
for those that don't know who zlatan is
because there might be some people that
are not familiar let's just read this so
zlatan who is a
superstar soccer player okay i mean top
10 in the world right now i don't know
if he's top ten he is probably
one of the most you know or maybe not
today at his prime because right now
he's in his late 30s but
at his prime this guy was a ridiculous
talent coming in everybody six five
powerful gets in your face he's buzzing
creation yeah okay is it cool if you've
ever seen his highlight just type in
google zlatan fights he is
a beast of a guy right so he goes out
there and he's a guy that's known for
saying what's on his mind he says lebron
james is a phenomenal of what he's doing
but i don't like it when people with
some kind of status
and they do politics at the same time as
what they're doing
i mean do what you're good at so zlatan
calls out
uh uh uh lebron james so now lebron
james has to respond back and this is
what lebron james says
he says there's no way i will ever just
stick to sports
um there's no way i will just stick to
sports there's gonna
he's uh i would never shut up about
things that's wrong
i preach about my people and i preach
about equality social justice racism
systemic voter suppression
things that go in our community because
i was part of my community at one point
and seeing the things that was going on
and i know what's going on still because
i have a group of 300 plus kids at my
school that's going through the same
thing
and they need a voice and i'm and i'm
their voice i'm their voice and i use my
platform to
continue to shed light on everything
that may be going on not only my
community but around this country and
around the world there's no way i would
just ever stick to sports because i
understand how
this platform works how powerful my
voice is
thoughts okay well i come from the same
background that
zlatan does and i'm a huge fan as you
can imagine he's
extraordinary as it relates to soccer
but i'm totally annoyed at him because
he has a huge platform
and he does use his voice to speak
up against racism and
he zlatan himself has experienced
tremendous amounts of hatred
because of his ethnic background and has
experienced racism
playing in europe so
i think as such high-profile global
stars
in two respective fields i think it's
incredible to use your voice to speak
out
and speak up about what things that are
really really important to you because
you have all these people across the
world listening to you
um and i feel he just kind of played
into this
um super conservative
in my mind racist
ploy of you know stay in your lane don't
you know
just shut up and dribble which i think
is awful
um he i know from what i read he admires
lebron
loves lebron um but
i don't think he should have
phrased it the way he did in that
but i also understand coming from where
we come from
particularly in former yugoslavia when
you talk about politics
you put yourself in a really
uncomfortable situation you just
were taught from early age never talk
about don't talk about politics
keep your mouth shut because you're
gonna get in trouble one way or another
it's almost like you you
associate fear we're talking about
politics
and so he's experienced so much
hatred zlatan has playing in different
fields even like recently was playing in
belgrade and
there was a huge racist rant they had to
apologize to him and he was
very stoic he just didn't say anything
and kind of like sucked it up so if you
think he should respond back absolutely
so
when if you have such a huge platform
and if you believe
in social equality and justice and and
people
being at least but what should he say
what should he's like if he's a player
and people scream stuff at him what
should he say
i don't think he should necessarily
respond to a particular person who's
being ignorant
or hateful or racist or whatever but i
think he should use twitter you talked
about technology
use your voice to say that's not cool
this is
this is what i've experienced and did
you see what happened to this basketball
player jeremy lin
in the g-league last week did you hear
about them asian names or calling him
so there's two there's two school of
thought here and it's and i i think at
this point it's just philosophical so
two two to jeremy land he's playing
basketball one of the opponents calls
him coronavirus because he's from china
said hey coronavirus say coronavirus so
he says i'm experiencing you know racial
slur comments you know people are kind
of saying
coronavirus so they said who said it he
said
i'm not going to go out there and tell
anybody on who said it because i don't
want to throw anybody under the bus
i just want to bring awareness to say
it's not appropriate
and i hear it but it needs to stop but
i'm not going to call anybody up
i thought his approach was actually very
respectful i liked the way he did it i
liked the way that he
uh uh took that and by the way earlier
this year something happened on lebron
at a game at an atlanta game i don't
know which game it was paul
when one of the fans started shouting at
lebron the husband and
him went at it and then they got kicked
out and then they asked lebron
afterwards so lebron what do you think
about what happened right now he says
well listen i'm just glad the fact that
fans are back because that's fans they
scream we go at it we go back and forth
that is normal that's going to be taking
place so you know
you know sometimes i wonder if some of
these athletes like zlatan is like
i just don't even want to get into the
political world just to get into the
world yet he has such a big platform
to use it is it right to use it or is it
better to take the michael jordan
approach and say look man i'm just not
getting into politics that's exactly
where i was going with this
is that you know michael jordan set a
precedent for
himself and athletes that he was going
to be apolitical even
in north carolina when i don't know if
it was jesse helms or whoever the hell
it was in north carolina was a blatant
racist
running against a black politician and
people
even as i think his mom and people in
this corner are like you gotta speak up
about this
like these are your people like what's
up and he's like you know what
famous famous quote republicans buy
sneakers too and he just
and he's been for a long time apolitical
i think even
during the blm and and blue lives matter
movement he donated
you know an equal amount of money to
both sides right lebron james different
character
lbj dga fee uh
lebron james don't give a f you know so
he has a voice he's gonna use it he's
not gonna just shut up and dribble
uh laura ingraham you know called him
out a few years ago and he's like no
but but i thought that was also a dumb
comment she made what do you mean just
shut up
yeah it's it's not about just shut up
and drop i just i think
like you know i think it's just a
different
level of res i like jordan's approach
i like jordan's approach of what he took
and i do think you talk about
your own but i also think there's an
element of lebron also been divisive
i think i think you're also dividing
america you said you've been polarized
by lebron you've been
vocal i'm not a fan i don't i don't
think he's a uniter i mean all this
stuff about united united united lebron
definitely it's not what's different
about what he's doing and what trump's
doing
dividing did i say trump's a united no
no no did you hear me at all
category not at all i think lebron and
trump are very similar mm-hmm
i think lebron to their base i think
lebron and trump are very similar
very similar the only difference is
trump converts lebron doesn't
lebron just gets his own audience but he
doesn't convert trump
used to convert trump is a conversation
no longer because he doesn't have a
platform
if he did he would continue he lost his
platform that's the point
yeah but what i'm trying to tell you is
lebron and trump believe it or not
are very very similar very similar well
jordan is in a league of his own
in the way he handled media and the way
he did everything
jordan reagan you know those guys you
put in a similar league of their own
john f kennedy these are in the league
of their own okay
reagan won 49 out of 50 states and even
democrats like the guy
okay john f kennedy even republicans
like them jordan even republicans like
him
you know even when uh jordan and barkley
were once on an oprah winfrey show
you know and they were teasing each
other and barclay actually there wasn't
but they were in the olympics and
something they we're playing he says hey
uh jordan mike why don't you tell
everybody who'd you vote for
for president none of your business yeah
i know you voted republican
so there is that uh that joke that
barkley would have with him
so but i like the way jordan did it uh
and quite frankly i
you know zlatan is probably sitting
there for zlatan to do this and you go
back to his history
yeah and he made some comments years ago
himself
that he used uh used his own platform he
made some comments saying there were
some comments made about me so he has
done it before
so there's a little bit of a hypocrisy
on zlatan's position as well because
he's
zlatan's like a trump for you to say
don't use your platform to say anything
you can say i disagree with lebron but
you can't say don't use your platform
the guy's going to use his platform
lebron can't say whatever he wants to
say if he agrees disagrees
he's earned the right to say whatever he
wants to say there's shots that comes
with it but he can say whatever he wants
to say
i think zlatan's one of those guys that
he's so witty
he's so smart he's so good with the
media
that he would actually make a decent
politician later on he would be
entertaining i'm being serious
and and by the way i think he likes
controversy as well so
he knows that everyone's going to be
talking about zlatan if
you know he goes against do you think
there was a little bit more behind this
when he said this comment you knew that
would get
picked up lebron would exchange now
we're talking about it on the phone
guess who's trending right now in the
past
fyi latin played for what team in the
soccer ac milan yeah
and then where did he play in us okay
who else was in l.a at the time
david lebron james so la you know
there's some stuff you know
these guys are competitive guys you know
when when zlatan came to if you ever
watch him play when he went and played
for galaxy
let me tell you people lost their minds
when this guy played i want to watch
this guy
i was on the grass watching zlatan play
it's ridiculous watching this guy play
live i mean like an analogy would you
like is he charles barkley of
soccer who is he's the lebron james of
soccer with his body because soccer
players are tiny but he's not
lebron james is like the greatest of all
time like stop it
like ronaldo would be a lebron please
get this ronaldo or
not ronaldo get
jordan's the greatest of all time jordan
would be like a pele that's what i mean
yeah jordan would be like a pele no what
i'm saying let me make sure
now that would be lbj let me make the
analogy that's a little better for you
yes please
is lebron the greatest human specimen
ever in the game of basketball
outside of shack physically physically
yeah yeah that's what you're saying
physically oh
he's i'm saying i'm saying iconically or
legendarily
game wise like he he's shaq
okay he's the shack of soccer it's the
best way to put it he's the shack of
soccer
let me tell you he pushed people around
he elbowed you in the face he slapped
you in the face he punched you he did
everything everything you're not
supposed to do better than zidane
oh league of his own yeah the guy was a
taekwondo black belt
who played soccer so he's known you know
he's a fighter and he's uh
you know he's a survivor he's aggressive
he's very very aggressive so you know
go type in zlatan kicks on youtube see
how he does
he would destroy a person if he kicked
him i love watching him too by the way
it's just it's it's a persona have you
seen this documentary
i have not seen it okay so the
documentary is a good one because they
record him when he's 17 years old and
he's going with his manager to go
negotiate the big contract
he's about to get a massive contract and
his uh uh
his manager is getting nervous and
zlatan 16 17 years old says
get your act together you're acting like
you're scared okay
act like you belong here tell us the 50
year old
he tells his 50 year old manager act
like you belong here why do you look so
nervous act like you've been here 16
17 year old kid telling that to you
because of himself in third person yes
he does so
zlatan you gotta love the guy and then
we go
so uh uh if you enjoyed today's podcast
and having sonata on
and adam on smash that subscribe button
sonata it's been great having you on
thank you so much for coming and
spending
with us uh i believe we are doing it
again
this thursday we are trying to get on
the routine to be doing it on a weekly
basis
uh so again this thursday 8 a.m same
time we'll be back at it again with the
podcast who's with us this thursday
daniel de martino booth yeah daniel de
martino booth will be here
this week with us on thursday take care
we got the best in real estate we got
the best in economics
we got the best same week thank you same
week sonata
we will do it again thank you so much
for coming out thank you bye-bye
thank you
you